Sure climate change is bad but at least it’s
not causing more cases of flesh eating bacteria
or something… no you’re kidding, seriously?
Hey global citizens, Julian here for DNews.
We talk about climate change a lot here, probably
because it’s a massive looming problem that
will affect the globe in profound ways.
You already know most of them by heart I’m
sure: melting ice caps, rising sea levels,
changing rainfall patterns that lead to droughts
and food shortages.
All bad stuff that’s in the not too distant
future.
But what if I told you that climate change
is causing problems already, and some of them
are truly unexpected?
Take for example a recent anthrax outbreak
in Siberia.
If you’re like me, you only know anthrax
as this white powder that gets mailed to someone
and then everyone freaks out because it could
kill you.
So you may be wondering what madman is mailing
a bioweapon to people in one of the most remote
places in the world.
But in reality, the bacterium that causes
anthrax infections, Bacillus anthracis, occurs
naturally and infects an estimated 2,000 people
each year.
Back in the early 20th century, anthrax outbreaks
were common in Siberia.
Anthrax infections killed over a million reindeer,
and they were buried in about 7000 burial
grounds by the indigenous Nenets.
But since then it’s been quiet, with the
last outbreak in Siberia happening in 1941.
Now the same bacteria that caused those outbreaks
could be responsible for the 20 Siberians
who contracted anthrax in August of 2016,
and I do mean the exact same bacteria.
The current hypothesis is after the infected
reindeer were buried, the bacteria were essentially
refrigerated by the permafrost heaped on top
of them.
Now that temperatures are climbing upward,
that frozen soil is starting to thaw, unleashing
spores across the tundra and infecting reindeer
and people anew.
If rising temperatures are the culprit, then
the Nenets can expect anthrax outbreaks every
summer.
There could be other dormant bacteria up there
waiting to be reawakened too, like bubonic
plague, or a disease that hasn’t occurred
naturally since 1977, smallpox.
Climate change might be doing more than revive
frozen microbes north of the Arctic circle;
it could be helping microbes closer to the
equator too, like Vibrio vulnificus.
That little guy is also known as a flesh-eating
bacteria, and it does well in warm and brackish
waters.
Guess what climate change causes more of?
Warm and brackish waters.
Global incidents of V. vulnificus have been
steadily rising for the last 4 decades.
Now there are about 80,000 cases in the US
each year.
Before you shout that correlation does not
necessarily equal causation and bring a tear
of joy to my eye like a proud parent, a study
in June published in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences found that warmer
surface ocean temperatures are causing blooms
of the bacteria and are associated with the
increased incidence of infection in Northern
Europe and the US Atlantic coast.
Most of the infections come from eating contaminated
seafood raw and in those cases the cholera-like
symptoms like diarrhea, cramping, and fever
usually pass after 3 days.
But Vibrio can also find it’s way into open
cuts, causing lesions that grow rapidly.
20% of the time these infections are fatal.
Climate change isn’t some far-off problem
with hypothetical impacts that will be felt
50 years from now.
It’s creating problems already, and some
of these problems come out of left field,
like these revived and revitalized bacteria.
Don’t worry though, because the hotter temperatures
can kill bacteria too!
Except that’s happening in deserts, where
the bacteria helps keep the soil from eroding.
Seriously climate change, can you just chill
out?
Another unexpected side effect of climate
change?
A refugee crisis.
Seeker Stories has more info on that here.
And climate change might be happening faster
than we expected.
Trace has more info on that, here.
Now have you noticed the changing temperatures
affecting your life in ways you didn't expect?
Like I for one basically can't play PC games
anymore without my room turning into a sauna.
Let us know in the comments, subscribe for
more and I will see you next time on DNews.